so this dish is definitely a party rice
it just makes you want to get up and
dance hi my name is tay and today i'm
gonna be making at my family's recipe
for garne angelo my surprise is a West
African dish where the rice is cooked in
a tomato base - growing up as a Ghanaian
in London no matter what party I went to
there was always two NatWest whether it
was a wedding a christening or even
someone's 16th birthday party a Ghanaian
party without your eyes it's like a
wedding without the cake although they
look smooth these peppers pack a serious
punch so if it's not for you be careful
how much you use over one day when
visiting Ghana I went to an arts house
and she cooked look right I don't know
how much leverage you put in it but my
whole face went red I was sweating
usually because the love glass will be
cooked by arts even grandparents where
they'll cook it in big pots that usually
need to be carried back up to people
into the venue there'll be music playing
in the background the kids have been
running around laughing giggling every
family gathering will get lively people
be drinking eating and dancing and just
laughing the whole night through some
countries just put everything in the
blender and cook it out one my mom cooks
it in part and a big difference is that
she also adds vegetables if I know you
and you haven't eaten get up fast if my
family we're probably not ferns growing
up in a Duke a food played a vital role
in bringing a family together and just
reminding us about our culture
no matter where you're from in West
Africa your love life is just something
that you can always expect at a party
and when you're clearing up you can
always expect to find grains on the
dance floor
mmm mom would be felt
hi my name is Cano and today I'll be
making Kenyan pull out flowers one of
the dishes that really shows the
diversity in Kenya within our food for
Masai people we don't use a lot of
spices as maybe people on the coastal
part of Kenya but I love playing our
spices so I had just a little bit to
make it a little bit more exciting
so when developing my own recipe for
pulao I really just handled in all the
best private
now the best plows I've ever had always
always always have meat-and-potato I
don't know what it is about that double
search thing but when I have cloud
without potato it just feels wrong I
think the thing I love about Kenyan
parties is that it's always about food
our parties aren't one of those where
you turn up and then food is ready then
you eat I'd be a very short party if you
just turned up to eat because then what
would you do all the parties that I've
been to the cooking is happening during
the party it's almost like the cooking
is the party itself people are a fact
they're grilling they're barbecuing
they're hanging out around what's being
cooked to socialize and honestly I think
the best parties revolve around food all
right now it's time to party hi my name
is amal and today I'll be making my
family's recipe for Somali buddies but
each is a dish which literally
translates into rice it has a lot of
ways that it's made typically it
consists of rice a bunch of spices and
some type of meat on top but ace is made
by a lot of people my family every time
I have it it's a little different
depending on who makes it it's one of
those dishes that is hard to get wrong
so if you do get it wrong probably
aren't a good cook no shade the spice
bun that's typically used for Somali
buddy's dishes is called how much which
literally translates into spices but
these can be served at a variety of
parties I think one of the most
important parties that it's served at is
wedding so you're at a Somali wedding
typically a lot later than you bargained
for the bride or groom is not there it's
like 11 p.m. but some nice amazing
person has decided to get the food out
early you're ecstatic and what's the
first thing they bring out the biddies I
don't think I've ever been to a Somali
wedding without buddies maybe the bougie
ones the raisins are my favorite part
it's always a topping that really
completes the dish the food coloring on
the fries isn't a mandatory stuff but it
just makes the fries look more fun and
everyone's have fun with anybody's I did
not make the connection that these were
also French fries for a really long time
but I was like these are just fun
potatoes lead on top of our patties
community is a huge part of the Somali
culture and
is reminiscent of that my mom and my
aunt helped me learn this dish that's
another reason why the bond the family
is so important especially do food the
end-all-be-all somali dish is the banana
you can't have buddies without banana
and I don't care who tells you otherwise
it's what makes it the most special it's
like home hi I'm Kiki Camuto and today
I'm showing you how to make my family's
Cape Verdean a toasty memory school
traditionally we use calamari or octopus
we put in a lot of shrimp and mussels as
well to have right on top those are kind
of the three staple ingredients that we
have in this type of rice so you can
find this dish at just about any Cape
Verdean party we love having some sort
of rice dish present we actually have
multiple dishes of rice there Cape Verde
is definitely a party country and I
think a lot of West African cultures
celebrate food really really big and
really really loud Cape where it is no
exception to that it's a country that
thrives off of its music its food and
its hospitality which i think is very
similar to a lot of West African
countries at any Cape Verdean party you
can find a whole bunch of your cousins
cousins you haven't even known about so
you'll meet your cousins for the first
time there you'll meet your aunts uncles
grandparents usually you'll just be
walking around to tables and greeting
everyone saying hi giving them kisses on
the cheeks so your rice is going to be a
little bit more sticky than you think at
the end of the dish we add a little bit
of the broth that we make with a seafood
mixture once everyone's eaten which is
obviously the most important part of the
party everyone will be on the dance
floor so you'll be dancing with your
grandma your grandpa anyone it's really
really loud the energy is super upbeat
and vibrant and it just makes you want
to get up and dance
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]